Progressive lawmakers are pushing
President Biden towards Nationwide rent
control they wrote a letter how nice
that says quote and corporate price
gouging in the real estate sector the
rent is too high and millions of people
across the country struggling to stay
stably housed as a result and while Joe
mulls it over he's rolling out a plan to
Target landlords by using multiple
federal agencies but get this more than
70 percent of rental properties are
owned by individuals many of whom are
seniors and live off the payments so
basically they want to kill all the
seniors Dana you know it's funny off the
cliff yeah throw granted look landlords
I'm a pro-landlord person I'm not a
landlord but I they got screwed for part
of most of the lockdown a lot of people
didn't pay their rent and uh and but
they they took it on the chin don't you
don't you think there was nothing that
they could do and then President Biden
was pushed into trying to extend it by
the squad remember this the Corey Bush
congresswoman from St Louis she slept on
the steps of the Capitol to make her
Point even though Nancy Pelosi said I
don't think we can do this it's not
constitutional they did it anyway and
guess what it's not constitutional so
that finally ended but there are a lot
of people who in order to achieve the
American dream they figure out a way to
buy some properties and then they rent
them and then they build like that in
terms of their their nest egg I really
hate PR by letter
never liked that like you wrote a letter
so now you're going to do a segment on
the five however this type of stuff is
happening all across the country they're
trying to do it in Colorado now but just
look at big cities that you don't want
to be like in San Francisco for example
or La it's not just the rent control but
if you prevent people from building new
housing guess what you're going to get
less housing when you have less housing
you have these problems where the rents
go up because of supply and demand
exactly it's all about supply and demand
it's not about price gouging though I
have to say Jesse I think you would make
an excellent slum Lord not a landlord
but I think as a slum Lord somebody that
no one ever sees pulls up in like a
really old Rolls-Royce Drives By You
Know throws your litter onto the ground
and then you drive on then you and then
I would own projects up and down I think
you would be you would be notorious no
one would know what you look like
why is the rent too damn High
well because
mortgage rates are too high we'll wire
mortgage rates too high because interest
rates are too high why are interest
rates too high because inflation is too
high why is inflation too high because
we shut down the country put all our
factories in China and spent trillions
of dollars we don't have
so now the politicians that made the
mistake want to fix the mistake that
they made you cannot let politicians fix
their own mistake they just have to stay
out of it yep Harold you seem to think
that there's something else going on
here that we're not touching on although
you might agree with 80 of what we're
saying 82 it all comes back to China but
like remember that guy that ran for
mayor yeah New York said the rent the
guy where the club damn High party I
mean that was that was his whole so look
high prices I I think what they're doing
I understand what they're trying to get
at here and it's they wanted the
foundation of is a blueprint for renters
Bill of Rights to ensure that renters
have some protections because as Jesse I
think Appley said uh the cost of housing
has gone up for a variety of factors and
without question interest rates upward
pressure on interest rates is what
really is driving that so you're gonna
you still have people needing a place to
live so rental properties and Rental
opportunities or for that matter are
rising so I get what the administration
is trying to do is this absolutely the
right way to do it no but if we all are
going to focus on it and we focus on two
things things the cost of housing in the
country because if people can't live in
the communities that we want them to
work whatever their job may be there's a
problem and two
are those landlords be they whatever you
want to call yourself what landlords are
they being fair with those who are
renting I think these are legitimate
questions I hope they get to the right
answers they're on to off to the good
start but I'm not sure that a a rental
cap is necessarily the right way to go
about doing it well I think the
difference is a landlord will fix the
broken heater a slum Lord won't yeah
that's why I think Jesse would be a slum
Lord
don't dare to dream passive income yes
exactly let them free judge I think the
key word in uh rent control is control
right it's always going to be about
controlling something yeah well if we
have less housing than we need so then
the question is why do we have less
housing because we have more people and
we have more people thanks to Joe Biden
and Joe Biden for the pregnancy rates in
the country I'm blaming him for two and
a half million people who came in in the
last what is it two years and nine
hundred thousand gotaways uh we've got
millions of people more than we expected
and let me just say that you know the
the landlords took a beating during the
pandemic they took a beating you know
they had tenants many of whom were
capable of paying but who refused to pay
because they knew that they had the
upper hand I don't like the federal
government getting involved in this I
don't like anyone getting involved in
this I believe in in uh in free
enterprise here and you know the the
cost of rent should depend upon the area
and what people are willing to pay there
you go did you get all that slim Lord
that's right and stop gentrifying my
neighborhoods oh really yes yes that's
also another problem it's been
destroying your income hasn't it oh god
oh the fastest I wanna Brian kill Mead I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now